je suis fier d'avoir porté les couleurs
de mon pays le moment de la retraite est
souvent douloureux la cassure fait mal
la transition encore plus marianne
st-gelais en a arraché ces derniers mois
j'ai tellement de choses difficiles mais
le plus gros est fait de se retrouver
tout seul
du jour au lendemain l'ancienne
patineuse de vitesse a perdu ses repères
son horaire ses entraîneurs ses amis le
vide comme chez plusieurs retraités
épaissi mais je t'aime négative mais pas
bougé de ma maison c'est tout était
vraiment dans une zone dont un petit peu
plus vraiment comme grease voir noir ma
famille est à rexingen fait que j'ai pas
de 2,2 de contact direct avec eux ou qui
loge vous savez poserait soupe est maman
est ce possible
marianne a préféré attendre d'accrocher
ses patins avant de se recentrer
avant de se bâtir une nouvelle vie est
sculpteur une salle de libre pour des
clients un trésor tout le contraire pour
le champion de ski acrobatique alexandre
bilodeau celui qui sera officiellement
comptable en mars prochain avait
planifié sa sortie quatre ans auparavant
retour à l'école conférences et stages
ça ça a été quelque chose qui était
récurrent mais mon psychologue sportif
qu'on me compare souvent le ski c'est ce
que je faisais sais pas qui je suis
pendant les jeux de sotchi j'avais un
coup renversé jamais savoir où d'autres
problèmes ailleurs un examen qui
semblait que j'avais pas le temps trop
trop d'étudier puis ça a commencé à me
stresser pour moi c'était ça me sortez
la pâte du ski
sophie brassard et conseillère en
orientation et s'occupe du programme
plan de match à l'institut national du
sport conduit l'entraîneur sait si vous
nous laisser gérer toute la vie de
l'athlète en dehors de son sport il vaut
mieux performer dans son sport parce que
la pression va diminuer il sera plus
stressés ils se demanderont pas en
arrière dans sa tête si je rate cette
personne en cela que va devenir ma vie
l'objectif guider les athlètes vers leur
nouvelle vie avec toute une gamme de
services la clé selon elle c'est de leur
faire voir autre chose que le sport
comme les études et forcé à prendre des
décisions pour tes études pour des
travaux d'équipement des forces et avoir
une structure externe de transport à te
déplacer à rencontrer des gens d'autres
gens donc ça alimente un petit peu ton
identité autre que le sport puis ça va
diminuer les impacts
samuel girard n'a que 22 ans et déjà il
suit des formations mais trop peu
d'athlètes imite ce champion olympique
de patinage de vitesse marianne
st-gelais elle est allée chercher les
mêmes outils à la retraite
c'est là qu'elle a pu valider son
intérêt pour les communications
al - la journée si le milieu des
affaires assouvi le côté compétitif
d'alexandre bilodeau et même s'il avait
tout prévu
la transition a été difficile ce pass
est le meilleur au monde dans ce que tu
fais tu es dans les médias et des
traités tout le monde parle de toi puis
par la suite sud de ton ode à
l'université puis dans le fond de la
classe puis après personne qui te calais
puis est aussi bon que tout le monde qui
même des fois un peu plus de travail à
faire
c'est vraiment pas terminée là mais en
vain que le côté sombre et lugubre
derrière difficile quand la vie commence
par le dessert